hi everyone my name is juan juan liu and
today i'll be talking about our work on
near-optimal distributed implementations
of dynamic algorithms for symmetry
breaking problems this is joint work
with shiri and taki and shai solomon at
tel aviv university
to start a vast majority of earlier work
on graph algorithms focus on the
sequential centralized setting
furthermore these works usually
considered static algorithms where the
solution to a problem is recomputed each
time from scratch
often these algorithms must be run on
very large networks we've included here
on the slide some examples of publicly
available data sets of several large
social networks you can see the number
of edges range from millions to 100
billion edges and these sizes are only
for publicly available data sets the
private network graphs collected by some
companies could be even larger up to
trillions of edges
moreover real world networks are often
dynamically changing with new edges
being inserted and deleted every second
social networks for example host new
collect connections every second these
changes change the topology of the graph
which means that static algorithms would
often need to be rerun several times to
obtain accurate statistics on very large
graphs with billions of edges
even linear time static algorithms are
too expensive to be re-run many times as
the graph changes
this then naturally motivates the study
of dynamic graph algorithms which are
also traditionally studied in the
sequential centralized setting
unlike static algorithms dynamic
algorithms we compute part of the
solution after each update instead of
recomputing the entire solution from
scratch as in static algorithms
this allows such algorithms to spend
less time computing a solution compared
to re-running the static algorithm
multiple times thus the quality measure
we care about for dynamic algorithms is
the update time or the time required to
compute a solution after updates
the goal of sequential centralized
dynamic algorithms is to minimize the
this update time
and here's an example of a very simple
dynamic maximal independent set
algorithm
suppose we have an edge deletion
indicated in red here between u and v
after we delete the edge u checks all
his neighbors to see whether it has any
neighbors in the mis
u in this example doesn't so we add it
to the amis
for an edge insertion if the insertion
occurs between two nodes in the mis here
in this example the insertion is between
u and w
we remove one of them from the mis
w here
we can cause one of his neighbors x here
to be added
one nice aspect of the sequential
centralized model is that we can access
all the vertices on one machine
however given today's large graphs with
billions or even trillions of edges it
often requires too much memory and time
to process the graph sequentially on
only one machine
naturally the next step is to then split
the large graph among many different
processors or machines
where each node is a processor or
machine
and edges are communication links
between the machines
nodes can send messages to each other
via the edges
and in this paper we consider the
multicast model where nodes can choose
to send the same or different messages
to some or all neighbors
nodes can use multiple rounds of
communication to send messages
where in each round they can send
messages to the same or different
neighbors
the message complexity of a distributed
algorithm is the number of messages sent
in total over the entire course of the
algorithm
in this paper we consider the congest
model where messages have all of log n
size
a problem with sending too many messages
is that it can overwhelm the network
bandwidth and i'll talk a bit more about
this problem later on
another complexity measure we care about
is the round complexity which is defined
as the number of rounds the algorithm
uses
one problem with having too many rounds
is that it takes too long for the
algorithm to compute a solution and it
can also result in the algorithm sending
too many messages
distributed distributed networks can
also be dynamic where edges are added
and deleted from the network
such dynamic changes also change the
communication topology of the network
on these dynamic distributed networks
the grand prize we seek to obtain for
dynamic distributed algorithms is to
have message complexity that matches the
update time of the best known sequential
centralized algorithm while also
maintaining all of one round complexity
furthermore and even better
characteristic which we achieve in our
paper is that the algorithm is robust
against adaptive adversaries adaptive
adversaries are defined to be
adversaries which determine the next
update or the edge changes in the graph
after they see all the previous outputs
of the algorithm
deterministic algorithms are naturally
robust against adaptive adversaries and
all the algorithms presented in our
paper are deterministic
a number of previous works have studied
dynamic distributed algorithms but most
have focused on minimizing round
complexity
these works operate in the setting of
dynamically changing distributed
networks
and some very recent works have also
studied simultaneously handling many
concurrent updates
however the algorithms in these works
operate by sending messages to all
neighbors via broadcasts
this means that the number of messages
required by these algorithms is at least
omega of delta where delta is the
maximum degree in the graph
this also means that the number of
messages sent can be as large as omega
of m for sparse graphs
surprisingly
very few previous works consider the
number of messages sent by the algorithm
after dynamic updates as a complexity
measure
there are many practical real-world
situations where few messages may be
required
some examples include systems with poor
wireless connections
an oversaturated network where many
independent agents are on the same
network
or a mobile data network in a poorly
connected area
our work focuses on using multicasts for
nodes to send messages to specific
subsets of their neighbors not all of
their neighbors
a few works have studied message
complexity for certain problems
assadi unlac shiber and solomon gave a
ofm to the three fourth amortized
message complexity and of one round
algorithm for mis
plague and solomon gave an o of alpha
over epsilon worst case message
complexity and of one round algorithm
for one plus epsilon
maximum cardinality matching
here alpha is a graph property known as
adversity which is a measure of graph
local sparsity
alpha could actually be quite large it
could be as large as square root of m in
general graphs
finally kaplan and solomon gave an of
log n amortized messages low out degree
orientation algorithm in o of one
amortized rounds for constant alpha
in light of these previous works and to
reiterate what we said before
before we move on to our main results
the gold standard for dynamic
distributed algorithms is that the
message complexity matches the update
time of the best known sequential
centralized algorithm while maintaining
of one round complexity
there are a number of challenges for
adapting centralized dynamic graph
algorithms to the distributed setting
first it is difficult for all nodes to
determine the number of edges in the
graph if updates on a disconnected
components of the graph occur
because the edges represent
communication links
two disconnected components have no way
to communicate
with each other how many edges are in
their respective components
this is an issue because many algorithms
use such information
second
many centralized algorithms perform
global restarts where a large portion of
the graph recomputes some information
such a global restart in the distributed
setting would mean that information must
be propagated throughout much of the
network
which could result in both high round
and also high message complexity
here's an example
suppose the restart starts from this
yellow node shown in this graph
and the restart propagates to the
neighbors of node
and to their neighbors and so on
until it propagates to a large part of
the network
this takes diameter number of rounds and
while a global restart may not reach
every single node in the network it
could still take omega of the diameter
number of rounds
the solution to these challenges is to
consider information from the partial
local neighborhood not the entire graph
using the local neighborhood reduces the
round complexity
and using a portion of the local
neighborhood or the partial local
neighborhood reduces the message
complexity
we study a number of symmetry breaking
graph problems in our paper including
delta plus one coloring
maximal matching
three halves approximate maximum
matching
and maximal independent set
and our algorithms achieve this grand
prize up to polylog factors in the
message complexity as well as the rounds
specifically for delta plus one vertex
coloring and maximal matching we show
dynamic distributed algorithms using all
square root of m messages and of one
rounds
both worst case
and the message complexity exactly
matches the update time of the best
known sequential centralized algorithms
both of these results use dynamic edge
orientation techniques where we maintain
edge orientations dynamically such that
the edges are approximately oriented
from nodes with smaller degree to their
larger degree neighbors you can refer to
our paper for specific details about
these algorithms
we also give an o of square root of m
amortized messages of log delta worst
case round algorithm for three halves
maximum matching
using the high degree low degree
partitioning technique with surrogates
formulated first by naaman and solomon
while in the centralized algorithm the
number of edges is always known it is
not known in the distributed setting as
i mentioned before
we show in our paper that using the
serragus also allows us to do a low
degree high degree partitioning of
vertices by looking at only a partial
two-hop neighborhood of each vertex
this also matches the best known
sequential centralized algorithm in
message complexity
and the number of rounds obtained is a
polylog factor from one
and to find out more about this
algorithm please also refer to our paper
finally the rest of this talk will focus
on our main result for maximal
independent set or mis where we give an
algorithm that achieves of m to the two
thirds log squared n amortized messages
and all of log squared n amortized
rounds using a high degree and low
degree partitioning
this partitioning is obtained by using
only a local six half neighborhood
the other main components of our
algorithm are
our use of a small diameter static
algorithm for high degree vertices and a
dynamic mis algorithm for low degree
vertices
this matches the best known sequential
centralized algorithms by up to polylog
n factors
a maximal independent set is defined as
a maximal set of vertices where no two
vertices in the set are neighboring
edge insertions may violate the
independence of the vertices as shown in
this example where two vertices that are
adjacent to each other are both in the
mis after this edge insertion
while edge deletions may violate
maximality
as you can see in this example
where after the edge deletion indicated
in red
and other new vertex is added to the mis
as shown by this yellow vertex here
as mentioned previously asari onak
shiber and solomon provide a
deterministic dynamic distributed mis
algorithm
that uses ofm to the three-fourth
amortized messages and of one amortized
rounds
however their algorithm uses one crucial
characteristic of the graph which is
that the graph remains connected
throughout all the updates
compared to this previous result we
improved the message complexity
polynomially while only
paying a polylog n factor in the number
of rounds
and most importantly we obtain our
result without making any connectivity
assumptions
a result built upon the sequential
centralized dynamic mis algorithm of
gupta and khan
their algorithm partitions the nodes
into high degree and low degree notes
where the cutoff for this partition is
that m to the two thirds
mis membership priority is given to low
degree nodes so the nodes with degree
less than m to the two thirds
and this means that a low degree node
will will add itself to the mis if it
has no other low degree neighbors in the
mis
high degree notes are only added to the
mis after processing the low degree
nodes and they are added if they have no
neighbors in the mis
low degree notes which enter or exit the
mis can cause many high degree nodes to
either enter or leave the mis gupta and
khan handles this by performing a global
restart after every edge update which
finds a new mis among all high degree
nodes in the graph
there are two main challenges we need to
solve in distributing the gupta and khan
algorithm
first of all we need to determine the
high degree and low degree nodes as m
changes and when the graph may be
disconnected when the graph is
disconnected as i mentioned before
nodes have no way to find out the number
of edges in the graph because they
cannot communicate across disconnected
components
this is in contrast to the case when the
graph is connected throughout all
updates in that case the nodes can find
out the number of edges in the graph
through a broadcast to the entire
network
however this assumption is not quite
realistic for real world networks
the second challenge is how do high
degree nodes compute whether they need
to enter the mis in a small number of
rounds and messages
a global restart which looks at all high
degree nodes takes too many rounds
in fact it can take up to diameter
number of rounds in the distributed
model
so for high diameter graphs like real
networks that is too expensive
so now i'm going to describe our
distributed algorithm and i'll start
with a very high level description
our distributed algorithms works in the
following way
as in gupta and khan low degree vertices
have priority in entering the mis
on an edge insertion
an endpoint removes itself from the mis
if the edge insertion violates
independence
in this example
one of the endpoints of the insertion
removes itself
after the vertex removes itself its
neighbors are added to the mis if
maximality is violated
low degree neighbors have priority in
adding themselves to the mis
after the low degree neighbors have
added themselves to the mis potentially
a large number of high degree vertices
may need to remove themselves from the
mis
in this example one high degree node
needed to remove itself from the mis
so we remove it
and finally if there are any remaining
high degree vertices that need to enter
the mis they proceed to do so but these
high degree nodes need to determine an
mis in the inducer graph amongst
themselves and we'll talk a bit later
about how they decide which ones will
enter the mis
on an edge deletion
maximality may be violated and so
neighbors are added to the mis if
possible giving priority to low degree
nodes in this example a high degree node
is added to the mis since no additional
low degree nodes may be added
as in the case for insertions there are
potentially many high degree nodes that
may be added or removed from the mis as
a result of a single low degree node
entering or leaving the amis
there are some important things
to consider about the algorithm i just
described so let me mention them now
first edge insertions
or deletions may cause nodes to switch
their degree designation so low degree
nodes may become high degree and vice
versa many times throughout the course
of the entire algorithm over many
updates
then when an edge update causes a low
degree node to enter or leave the mis
the dynamic algorithm of aoss 18 is run
on the low degree node to determine its
set of low degree neighbors to add to
the mis
while several low degree nodes may enter
the mis as a result of a edge update at
most one low degree node ever leaves due
to an update specifically due to an edge
insertion
low degree nodes that enter the mis can
cause many high degree nodes to leave as
we mentioned before
and similarly
low degree nodes that leave the mis can
cause many high degree nodes to enter
while gupta and khan perform a global
restart at every update step among all
high degree nodes to determine the set
that enters or leaves the mis
what we do instead is that we perform a
local restart on the set of high degree
nodes in the local neighborhood only
when needed
and we will give specific details on
this procedure in the next few slides
tying our algorithm back to the
challenges this entire algorithm hinges
on the fact that we need to know which
nodes are high degree and which are no
degree which is a non-trivial hurdle to
overcome and furthermore we need to know
when nodes become high degree from low
degree and vice versa
and we solve the second challenge i
mentioned before by performing a local
restart only when necessary compared to
the gupta anchor algorithm which
performs a global research in the
centralized model among all high degree
nodes after every update step
now we'll give
more details on how we solve challenge
one which is how to determine low degree
high degree designations
to solve challenge one we initialize the
counter pv for every node v which starts
with value 1
assuming that we start with an empty
graph
all vertices are initially low degree
and when the degree of any vertex
exceeds 2pv due to edge insertions
for example vertex v in this diagram
where vertex v
exceeds degree 2.
the vertex then makes itself high degree
the node v then updates pv to equal its
current degree when it becomes low
degree again
this procedure may result in too many
high degree nodes importantly
we don't deal with them now we make high
degree nodes low degree again when we
perform a local restart
and as i mentioned before local restarts
are only performed when we need to
determine which high degree nodes need
to enter the mis
the rest of the procedure then boils
down to solving challenge two which is
determining the set of high degree nodes
that need to enter the mis
suppose in the example the highlighted
yellow nodes are in the mis
on an edge insertion a low degree
neighbor may need to leave the mis in
this example you or his neighbor must
leave amis
so suppose you left the mis then there
may be many high degree neighbors that
want to enter the mis in this in this
example x y and v
no longer have any neighbors in the mis
so they all want to enter but of course
not all of them can enter because there
are some edges connecting them
so they must determine an mis in their
induced neighborhood which would tell
you which ones will be added to the mis
before we run the algorithm for
determining which ones will enter we
must go back and solve challenge 1 again
since some of these quote-unquote
high-degree notes may actually be low
degree
uh recall from before we haven't
actually yet
dealt with these high degree vertices
which have become low degree due to
deletions
so to determine the set of high degree
vertices that have become low degree we
first determine the set of degrees of
all nodes in the one hop neighborhood of
the low degree vertex that we initially
removed from the mis in this example
that vertex is u and the sum of the
degrees of this one half neighborhood is
12.
then any vertex with degree less than
the sum raised to the two thirds becomes
low degree
in this example x and y both have less
than 12 to the two thirds degree so they
become low degree
vertices which became low degree
have priority in joining the mis
and so
both x and y in this diagram join the
mis
suppose instead
x and y remain high degree after doing
our local restart
we run a static distributed mis
algorithm on the induced subgraph of
high degree nodes in the local
neighborhood of u
the specific algorithm we use is the
static algorithm of sensor hello porter
and swartzman which operates in
polylogin rounds on small diameter grass
as you can see in this example this
induced subgraph has small diameter and
in fact the diameters of the subgraphs
we look at in our algorithm are at most
six
specifically their algorithm requires a
leader
and so in our case the low degree node
which removes itself from the mis
initially
is the leader
in this example
you becomes the leader
because their algorithm is deterministic
it requires all the nodes participating
in the algorithm to communicate
information with the leader over several
polylog rounds
this is the reason why
small diameter is important in order to
obtain polylog and total rounds for the
entire algorithm
running their algorithm in this example
we pick v to join the mis
the message complexity of our algorithm
is o of m to the two thirds log squared
and amortized
where m is the average number of edges
over all updates we also show the same
result for maximum number of edges
this message complexity is due to the
fact that low degree vertices have
degree of m to the two thirds
and there are at most of m to the
two-thirds edges in the local high
degree neighborhood
finally this bound is amortized because
the lojo restarts which determine
whether any high degree nodes become low
degree is amortized
the log squared n factor comes from the
number of rounds our algorithm runs
our algorithm requires both log squared
and rounds because cp as 20 the static
algorithm that we use for finding the
mis among the high degree neighbors
requires all log squared and rounds on
constant diameter graphs
as in this example here and as i
mentioned before we only ever run our
algorithm on local subgraphs with
diameter at most six
the amortization in the bound comes from
running aoss 18
on the low degree neighbors and this
algorithm requires of one amortized
rounds
and that concludes the technical portion
of this presentation um so to conclude
with some final thoughts we initialize a
formal study of message efficient
distributed dynamic algorithms we show a
number of results that achieve the grand
price
up two of log squared and factor or
smaller
in obtaining these results we solve
several rather general challenges such
as an unknown number of edges or how to
perform restarts efficiently and locally
there are a number of questions that are
interesting as a result of our study and
we think that these questions will be
interesting directions to explore in
future work
and so these questions include can the
techniques in our paper be generalized
for y class of dynamic distributed
algorithms
can we achieve worst case balance
especially for the number of rounds for
mis
furthermore can we also
get rid of the o of log square and n
factors especially in round complexity
for mis
recall the log squared n factors were a
result of running the static algorithm
so can we perhaps use another technique
to get rid of them
can our algorithms be modified to handle
multiple concurrent updates while
maintaining low message complexity
and finally is there a general purpose
compiler which takes a centralized
dynamic algorithm and outputs a message
efficient distributed dynamic algorithm
so this is a very general question but
we think it would be very interesting if
we can provide such a framework for
turning centralized dynamic algorithms
to dynamic distributed algorithms where
the message complexity equals the update
time
and
we maintain all of one rounds
this is possibly the way to achieve the
grand prize
and with this i conclude our
presentation please check out our paper
and we're happy to take any questions
over email